american style shut down in europe maybe
so not as big as the federal budget
crisis and not yet a reality but
according to the eu's executive arm it's
on the horizon by mid-november unless
parliament agrees to a 2.7 billion euro
back extension of the 2013 budget meps
were incredulous when it was announced
some were a little suspicious they were
caught in inexplicable machinations
mep spent months wading through the 2014
budget including agreement of two blocks
of additional spending from 2013.
3.9 billion and 400 million euros you
can say that we are beginning to do
things the american way and we shouldn't
do it the american way we should do it
the european way where you pay your
bills in emergency meeting the budget
committee agreed to hold a vote this
thursday but insist their additional
spending is agreed before the end of
october
an historic moment for the european
parliament when aung sang tsuchi the
former burmese dissident now opposition
politician and democracy campaigner
received the sakharov prize for freedom
of thought 23 years after it was awarded
this is for me a joyous and a deeply
meaningful occasion the main aims of our
democratic movement was to bring about
national reconciliation but in order to
achieve this reconciliation we need the
help
of all our friends all over the world
good news for users of medical test
procedures and equipment and of medical
devices such as breast implants and hip
and knee replacements
parliament agreed to a more efficient
monitoring system of such devices in the
future however the proposal for tighter
evaluation of all products was watered
down under pressure from industry
lobbying
foreign
for spanish and hysterical story again
9